>> Bret: HEY GREG, HOW ARE YOU
YOU?
>> Bret: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
WE MIGHT BE NEARING AN ANSWER
FOR WHAT HAPPENED TO A SAUDI
JOURNALIST AFTER DISAPPEARING TO
GO TO THE SAUDI CONSULATES IN
AND STUMBLE TURKEY.
SOURCES NOW SAY THE SAUDIS WILL
EVENTUALLY ADMIT THAT HE MAY
HAVE BEEN KILLED ACCIDENTALLY
DURING AN INTERROGATION.
THAT NEWS COMES SHORTLY AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP SET HIS TOP
DIPLOMAT TO THE KINGDOM AND
TURKISH AND SAUDI ARABIA
INVESTIGATORS DO THAT FOR THE
CONSULATE.
WE HAVE COVERAGE TONIGHT.
JOHN ROBERTS IS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND TELLS US WHAT HE
IS HEARING THERE.
WE START UP WITH CORRESPONDENT
BENJAMIN HALL AND HIS TEMPLE.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, THESE REPORTS,
IF THEY ARE TRUE THEY WILL BLOW
THE CASES.
THERE HAS BEEN DENIAL BUT ALL
THE EVIDENCE HAS BEEN POINTED AT
SAUDI ARABIA.
AT THIS REPORT IS TRUE IT MEANS
THEY WILL FINALLY ADMIT TO BEING
INVOLVED IN THE MURDER.
>> 13 DAYS AFTER HE DISAPPEARED,
SAUDI ARABIA HAS STARTED TO
COOPERATE.
ON MONDAY HE ORDERED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE CASE.
WORKING IN TANDEM WITH TURKEY.
TURKISH AUTHORITIES HAVE BEEN
REQUESTING ACCESS TO THE
CONSULATE, SHOWING HE WENT
MISSING.
FINALLY TODAY IT HAPPENS.
FOR DAYS AUTHORITIES HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO GET INSIDE THE SAUDI
CONSULATE TO FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
THEY ARE NOW JUST ARRIVING.
SAUDI AND TURKISH INVESTIGATORS,
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
INVESTIGATORS SPENT AT LEAST
FIVE HOURS AT THE CONSULATE, A
SAUDI TEAM AND TURKISH FORENSIC
POLICE.
NOTABLY A CLEANING CREW ALSO
ARRIVED HOURS AHEAD OF THEM
BOTH.
NOW THE EUROPEAN UNION IS ALSO
LOOKING FOR ANSWERS.
>> I THINK WE ARE ON THE SAME
PAGE WITH OUR AMERICAN FRIENDS
ON THIS.
WE WAIT FOR HAVING MORE NEWS ON
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THIS.
>> ON SUNDAY, HE REACTED ANGRILY
TO PUT A GLOWING ECONOMIC
THREATS.
SAYING "THE KINGDOM CONFIRMS ITS
TOTAL REJECTION OF ANY THREAT
THAT AN TEMPS TO UNDERMINED IT."
SAUDI STATE MEDIA THEN SUGGESTED
A HIKE IN OIL PRICES TO $100 IF
NOT $200.
IN ANOTHER DEVELOPMENT,
KING SOLOMON AND THE PRESIDENT
OF TURKEY SPOKE BY TELEPHONE
WITH BOTH ATTEMPTING TO CALL ME
SITUATION.
>> THE KING REITERATED HIS
COUNTRY'S KEENNESS TO MAINTAIN
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH TURKEY THE
SAME WAY IT IS AND THAT NO ONE
WILL RUIN THAT RELATIONSHIP.
>> PRESSURE ON THE SAUDIS MOUNTS
AS MORE BUSINESS SHOWS THEY WILL
NOT ATTEND THE CONFERENCE THIS
MONTH.
THE CEO OF BUBER, RICHARD
BRANSON HEAD OF THE WORLD BANK
AND THE HEAD OF JPMORGAN AMONG
THE FEW TO CANCEL.
IT IS ANOTHER MAJOR BLOW TO THE
SAUDIS.
>> THAT MAJOR NEWS REPORT
BREAKING TONIGHT, POTENTIALLY AT
SAUDI ARABIA ACCEPTING
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE MURDER IS
WHAT IS SHOCKING EVERYONE TODAY.
WHAT CONSEQUENCE OF THAT WILL